[Music]
this is the inside of rivian's factory
and this is wsj reporter Mike Elias now
while you might associate this Factory
with the r1t and r1s when Mike went
there he found something surprising a
huge chunk of this Factory actually
makes vehicles for just one customer
Amazon
the company ordered a hundred thousand
vans from Rivier and as it begins to
Electrify its delivery Fleet and the
scale of production at rivian's factory
shows just how important that contract
is Tink across the Auto industry
startups and Legacy oems are all
competing to try and win big contracts
to Electrify commercial vehicles but
what is it about these contracts that's
so important for automakers let's find
out
so right now there's a lot of momentum
in the US to Electrify commercial
vehicles like delivery Vans school buses
and even ambulances across private
companies and the government we have 600
000 Federal vehicles that we the federal
government owns they're going to all end
up being electric vehicles now there are
some 8 million commercial fleet vehicles
in the U.S and
fraction of all cars on the road
electrifying them is still creating big
business opportunities for Ev makers
it's clear to me that the Amazon piece
of their story is is a big one Mike saw
firsthand just what these Fleet
electrification contracts can mean for
automakers number one it gives you some
stability of of demand and you've got
this built-in demand over a multi-year
period I think that sort of stabilizes
you not only from a working capital
standpoint of having that money that's
been invested but also just knowing that
you've got one customer to focus on
you're not building custom orders for
thousands of different people that can
also help streamline your manufacturing
processes instead of building vehicles
that have a wide range of configurations
you can just build the same design over
and over again
so who has secured these contracts well
Amazon also has a deal with stellantis
for their Ram electric bands GM's
electric subsidiary bright drop is
making 500 electric vans for FedEx and
says it has reservations for Walmart
Hertz and Verizon and the biggest
commercial player in the US is Ford
Ford's always been uh sort of the 800
pound gorilla in the commercial vehicle
space they're going hard after these
these customers the company has an
electric van and its electric F-150
Lightning which it recently customized
for us police forces and then there's
canoe see in the first quarter of 2022
the fledgling EV startup issued a 125
million dollar loss and announced that
there was substantial doubt about the
company's ability to continue operations
but then canoe secured some commercial
contracts the company received an order
of 4 500 of its vans from Walmart and an
additional 12 300 100 binding orders
from two van rental companies now in the
third quarter of 2022 canoe was still
losing money but with production
starting in November these contracts
could prove to be the vital Lifeline the
company needs to stop it going bankrupt
but while Landing a contract to
Electrify a company's Vehicles can help
an automaker it doesn't always guarantee
their success see even if you have
demand for your Eves getting hold of
Parts like batteries Motors and other
supplies has been challenging for
automakers whether they're making
consumer vehicles or commercial ones and
prices are only getting higher yeah it's
great to have the demand and have
customers and contract orders in place
but it doesn't change the dollars and
cents of this being a super Capital
intensive business so watch this space
because with over 8 million commercial
vehicles on U.S roads you could be
seeing a lot more of this in the future
[Music]